hi I'm Tony and I work at water today we
are going to talk about an
implementation of party FM's part in the
Wolfram language you are going to see
how to represent symbolically RDF data
encourage using spark
hi I'm Tony I work at war from and I'm
working on our defense pocket
who of you knows what that is okay great
who has queried a sparkling point before
or worked with early Earth data well
okay not so many so let's introduce
these things and first motivate why we
want to do that so let's see what we did
traditionally if he wanted to say make a
plot of some data we got some
spreadsheets and somehow imported the
data and then made a plot of it and then
when we wanted to compare this curve to
some other data we would probably get
another spreadsheet and do the same
process again and then plot it in the
same plot and if you're not lucky the
curse would be totally separate and
wasted because the units were missing
and you have to manually find them in
the documentation of your dataset the
emphasis is on manually so now how do we
do that now so an example we want to
plot a map of things around us
now would we do that now we find a data
source in our case so called Sparkle
endpoint that contains a lot of data we
write a query that finds places around
us at a certain Center in a certain
radius and the things that it finds are
certain objects and we want the human
readable labels for this object so we
also define a label query and then we
put everything together we want to find
things around here in a radius of one
kilometer and the labels and we sent
this query to our Sparkle endpoint that
we chose then we get back some results
and then we can plot the whole thing in
a map
and what we see is for instance the
Illinois terminal so how was it possible
that this data could be shown in a map
directly it is because the information
that came back stored in the variable
location was something that is
meaningful to the world from language so
it could directly show it on a map and
we are going to see how that works in
general so the overview of this talk is
I'm going to introduce RDF the resource
description framework that is used to
describing information then sparkle
which is the query language for RDF and
then some future features that build on
top of that framework so RDF the
resource description framework
everything say Albert Einstein is a
resource to attach information to that
resource we create a so called IRI
resource identifier or internationalized
resource identifier because everything
is a resource even properties that we
use to label or describe these resources
they are also our eyes so they have
properties themselves and so on and then
there are some special things like
literals if you just have a string you
don't know what it means when its own
but in RDF each string is annotated with
a datatype and in this case it uniquely
this defines how the string is to be
interpreted namely as a temperature in
degrees Celsius
now that we have the basics we can start
making statements as you have seen
before
those are this was a short III but they
are usually longer because they have to
be unique globally or so I introduced
some shortcuts let's see for instance WD
of q1 gives me an ir i in vicky data and
i can even click on it then i get a
human readable description of the
yeah so this III identifies yeah stands
for the universe so now we can make a
statement this thing is of type person
yeah so that means about engine is a
person it's a machine readable statement
and then we can collect these statements
into RDF graphs this is an RDF store
which contains one or more graphs so and
now now that you have these identifiers
you might want to find some information
about them one way is to click on it to
get human readable information the other
way is to retrieve an RDF representation
of the information associated with that
item so this is one example I just say I
just resolved this IRI and say I want an
RDF representation turtle is one of the
possible C realizations of RDF data and
I get back an RDF store and it doesn't
just work for Vickie data
my favorite example but any other let's
say protein data or here I have an eye
about seconds yeah so what kind of
seconds this donor defines exactly what
it means so so once we have a machine
readable information about these
resources what can we do with them so
that's where sparkle comes in because
you could look at the triples that are
in the store but this is not the most
you this is not the most useful way to
look at it usually you might want to ask
more complicated questions and that's
what Sparkle is for so a quick crash
course in sparkle so here I have some
RDF store that I got from somewhere
maybe I imported it or traded myself and
then I want to ask to explore it what
are the properties in it so the syntax
is just you usually have a so-called
graph pattern or basic graph pattern
which is a list of triple patterns here
I have just one
pattern and these question marks signify
the start of a variable that means here
we have a triple pattern that matches
any triple in that store because we have
three variables and then we want to know
only the predicate variable the one in
the middle and we want to eliminate
duplicates so that's how we see what
kind of properties are in that earlier
store yeah
for instance a property called works at
or knows and now it's a second example
we can ask the same question but what
kind of subjects are in this or DF store
you know we see let's say Tony or Paco
or Andrew no and then we can ask where
does Tony work yeah we have a triple
pattern the first is an I I not a
variable in this time this one is a
property and this one is a variable and
we get back well works at Wolfram and
now we can go a little bit more
complicated find all the people that
work at Wolfram well it's a fake store
we won't find everybody button and then
for these people find the name yeah in
this case the label man and we get a
list of people so the way to think about
sparkle queries is one one object
connects to another object and that
might connect to further objects for
each of these connections you just write
down a triple or a triple pattern you
know wherever you don't have a literal
you put a variable and that's it what
you have to know about writing basic
sparkle queries so what can you do with
these Sparkle queries later I'm going to
show you some more features of sparkles
but this is the basic so let's define a
query that counts the triples in an RDF
store yeah
here we have again a local RDF store and
we applied this query to the store and
we get out yes four triples we can also
execute this query on a remote sparkline
point in this case we key data and we
send it there and back there get back
the answer just change it since
yesterday the other distinction is
symbolic verse versus query strings our
main feature as the symbolic queries but
in some cases when you are writing
queries manually you would probably use
a query string so with that very then
I'm sending to VG data I'm retrieving
for caffeine the chemical formula and
the image can execute it well it's the
same as yesterday no but I can write the
same query in symbolic form now so here
you have a sparkle select query there's
a list of triple patterns yeah here this
is caffeine this is the formula and this
is the image and you can make the same
result when would you use the symbolic
query when you start writing data
turbine applications you would compose
complicated queries from smaller
components and that's when you used it
so what does yes
that is the sparkle end point yeah so
some of the sparkle features we have
basic graph patterns like you have
already seen so here to triple patterns
and you have a condition that for
instance to find books published before
1980 water or you can find all the books
and if available the year so this is an
optional pattern you can have Union
patterns like either dead pattern or
dead pattern
no need to understand this is just a
quick overview of the features the power
of sparkle
now you can have negation for instance
find all the people that don't have an
email address specified so you can ask
them later property pass this is an
exciting feature of sparkle in which you
can start at a certain note it can even
be variable follow along a path along
certain properties let's say any person
that has a father and then where does
the father live in so or starting at a
person Tom and follow one or more no
edges of the property knows now so that
means find a big circle of friends of
Tom or aggregates you know the number of
books by author sub-queries Federation
is an interesting feature that means you
might have a data set and queried and it
might link to another data set from
which you want to retrieve additional
information that means part of the query
let's say you have some items in your
database and they link to wiki data you
can retrieve the image from Vicki data
that means one single query can be
executed on different parts can you
execute it on different sparkline points
and then the typical features of a query
language like solution modifiers like
ordering the solutions and slicing so
now
we have such a powerful query language
wouldn't be nice to query entities with
that language
yes we have some experimental feature
that we're not documenting yet because
it's not ready but considered that query
starting at a certain isotope or
followed the donor fleets one or more
steps and then apply that to an entity
type and you get back the daughter
nucleus of that isotope and it also
works for local entities you know
define your entity store you know some
things and there's a class called fruits
and then find all the things of type you
know fruits in here result so let's have
a comparison of sequel and sparkle so
there's one query I wanted to
demonstrate in both languages for
comparison one is fine two people their
father and the city image their father
lives yeah
so first in sequel so you would create a
table or maybe you have that already
that has US cities a city table you know
with the name of the city and a person
table this name of the person and the
father mother and listen and some
primary Keys fill in some data now and
the query looks like dead you join the
person table with itself and then you
join it again with the city table on
certain predicates and you get back the
result is expected well try to explain
to a little kit how you would write such
a query yeah yeah what is a join easy
outer product filtered by a predicate
here yeah now let's do the same in
sparkle so here you have the same data
set but prepared for rdf yeah so you
have a city
I call it city one that has a label
Madrid and mention and so much more and
then you have data about people yeah
you know dad one person one is a person
and has dead label and lives in their
city and family relations among them and
then this one is the same query but
using Sparkle and the only thing that
you have to look at is dead one
a person has fought a father you know
and then that father lives in the city
and that is easy to explain
you go from a person to the father and
from the father to the city and all the
other things are well those things that
you get back here are identifiers and
you want to human readable labels that
means for all the variables here you
retrieve the label same result but in my
opinion simple and easy to understand
query so wouldn't it be nice to query
relational databases using sparkle
because what is typically the problem if
you are in an organization that has
large relational databases if someone
wants to ask a question against these
databases they would ask the IT
department in natural language what they
want to know they would write the query
and a few days later they would come
back with the results and hopefully they
did not misunderstand the natural
language question so if if they could
vary their databases using Sparkle
people might be able to write the
queries themselves because they can sync
at the conceptual level you know in
terms of learning the vocabulary used in
the earlier representation as opposed to
thinking about technical details like
how's the data organized in the database
so and that is one of the future
features are to LML is a language for
mapping relational databases to RDF and
there usually two approaches to doing
that either
once you have such a mapping you convert
your database to an RDF for publication
or for loading it into an RDF database
or you create an audio view which means
you don't do any conversion but at query
time sparklers translated to sequel and
the result is back interpreted into that
typical
or perform at No so and how you would
say that abnormally as your IT
department would look at the database
and choose a vocabulary suitable for
your data yeah and write a mapping and
then integrated view or convert it to
RDF data depending on certain criteria
like it's the data frequently changing
then probably you would go with a view
of the data yeah and here's an example
about weather data which might be
frequently changing now so in this
example you create a table in sequel of
stations and observations which are
happening at a certain station and at a
certain point in time visit certain
measuring a certain temperature yeah
here insert some example data and then
write a mapping from this table to our
div this looks a little bit big but your
users won't have to do that it's doing
your IT department or some expert yeah
but what you can see is here you have a
station map that looks at a station
table and here's a template for the IR
eyes that are created for entries in
that table yeah similar for the
observation there's a map for the
observations yeah and one interesting
thing is that when you map the date
column you specify a data type and when
you map the temperature column you also
specify a data type that means after
this conversion you have semantically
meaningful information you know it's
supposed to Rev
row values in the database and now let's
do that so when you create a there's a
new object or future object
now the database already have store
which consists of the database and the
mapping and then you can create like
give me all the stations or using a
query string
find a station Madrid and then an
observation in that station and for this
observation give me the date and that
temperature yeah so that means on you
know this date you had 20 decrease
Celsius in the use cases if you have a
large data set that you can't convert or
if it's changing frequently and here is
another example
yeah but we don't have to go through
that that is one of the future features
or another interesting future feature is
entailment so let's look at let's look
at that example
oh I don't evaluate it here this example
is a small example birth rate has a
father worker yeah and this is metadata
about the properties you say his father
has a domain person and a range also
person so now one could wonder if has
father a property no by default however
if you enable RDF entailment you can
infer that his father must be a property
and why that because properties appear
in the predicate position yeah so some
certain this this additional triple is
implied by the existing triples under
RDF entailment so now we could wonder is
Wolfgang a person we can't say that
under RDF entailment because this
internment regime is too weak however
under rdf schema entailment we can take
additional information into account that
means under this one we can say that
Wolfgang is a person because Wolfgang
appeared in the
predicates position and we say that his
father has a range of person so that's
why we know that Wolfgang is also a
person that's what we can do under or
their schema attainment also other
things like if E is in Class C 1 and C 1
is a subclass of C 2 then we know that E
is also in C 2 and owl is a more
complicated language for expressing
constraints relations between classes
and properties and that's my talk any
questions
[Applause]